we get to send it over to Sherry now who
is picnicking here on this Tuesday
morning
this is fantastic and you know you guys
I've been talking about the breezes and
the winds coming today so maybe an
indoor picnic would be perfect so it's
Valentine's Day and most people try to
up the ante you know for those they love
something luxurious like a picnic
designed just for you and your loved one
or friends maybe your gal Pals joining
me today is the owner of pretty little
picnics baldella Beatty valdela this is
absolutely so romantic and so beautiful
it's a pleasure to meet you how long is
pretty little picnics been in business
actually in March we will celebrate our
first year your first year okay this is
so luxurious and it's so romantic so
tell us how did you get started with
this idea well I've always had a love
for planning events so I guess you would
say it started back home in Detroit I
loved always being a part of the events
or planning events and when our family
moved here we lost the opportunity so
being in Vegas you know it's full of
Glitz and glamor and they're heavy on
the experiences okay so I was able to
fulfill my need to plan events and also
provide an experience and we have a lot
of good weather here I mean a very few
days of bad weather right so uh what
kind of occasions would you set up a
pretty little picnic for for anything
that you're willing to celebrate uh
birthdays date nights
um anniversaries any type of Celebration
proposals and what are the settings or I
imagine you could do backyards
absolutely we usually do Parks but we
can bring it to you if we can bring it
to your workplace we can bring it to
your home your backyard by your pool so
your own vision is really sky's the
limit right as long as you have
permission to be in whatever setting you
would like to be in right I would assume
you have to have to make sure you have
the availability it's beautiful now you
you looks like you cater everything but
you don't
okay so it's gorgeous so a setting like
this including all the pillows the table
the crystal everything what would it
cost and for how long this particular
setup would run you about 450 and that's
for two hours for two I bring everything
I set it up and I take it down only
thing you do is show up and enjoy make
memories oh my goodness and you would
make some wonderful memories valdela
this is absolutely beautiful thank you
so so romantic and can you pick a color
scheme if you have something absolutely
but you go on our website we do have
some packages that you can pick from
okay yep and you can visit us visit us
at prettylittlepikniks.com wonderful and
pick some of those packages that we have
available wonderful well cheers Happy
Valentine's Day to you thank you so much
I absolutely love the idea and I think
you will too you just gave me some good
ideas for some good celebrations is
coming up pleasure to meet you thank you
thank you